wano recently wrapped up its main story
and okay that took a lot longer than
expected and so in celebration I thought
it could be fun to rank every single one
piece Arc in a tier list a good idea is
a good idea forever that's right the guy
that turned into a meme for saying that
every Arc was the best is gonna try and
rank this incredible collection of arcs
but first a small disclaimer I'm not a
super fan of this series I enjoyed the
story and these rankings are based off
of my own individual experiences which
given that I watched very little of the
anime and experienced it through
producing weekly reviews it makes my
experience with this series somewhat
unique I'd say you may agree you may
disagree you may find my ratings rage
inducing but look we're all friends here
we all love one piece and the detail
with one piece is most animes a tier
anyway so with that disclosed let's jump
into the list
[Music]
romance Dawn online with The Last Dragon
Ball video This One Piece One presents a
unique challenge how do I rank story
beats that build off of each other the
early arcs of One Piece are largely set
up and astronomically more
straightforward and simple than what
comes later on in the series and yet
without these valuable short arcs the
cataclysmic moments that occur later in
the series lose a lot of their value
this is the reason why I'm ranking these
based off of my enjoyment when I first
read them rather than how they make me
feel today in retrospect well at least
for the most part Roman Stone has a very
strong opening chapter that achieves a
tremendous amount in its short seven
chapter run establishing cornerstones
and plot lines that to this day have yet
to be delivered upon from which the
entire story has spawned it's simple but
even when I was reading it way back when
I could still appreciate the
characterization and setup not to
mention it pulls off some really strong
payoffs like Luffy learning the
difference between being courageous and
looking straight up for a fight and of
course Luffy allowing his actions to
speak for themselves to win over Zoro
when he was tied up this stuff is a
massively underappreciated I think
people might say that you can start
reading at the parade or arlong Park
arcs but to me that misses the point of
one piece and moreover cuts the soul out
of this amazing series I really enjoyed
romance Dawn when I was reading through
it the subtle hints the sort of
emotional writing Oda would become known
for really cemented as an a-tier
candidate for me next up it's Nami and
buggy the clown in the orange Town arc
when I first thought about writing this
video my initial thought was that I
would be having difficulty ranking the
early East blue material but to tell you
the truth I love these arcs and orange
town is no exception acting as the first
on what chunky Arc to contend with a
villain for a prolonged stretch of time
or his town manages to achieve a lot
more than many might realize outside of
the obvious establishing characters like
Nami and buggy that both become
Mainstays in this Pisces Adventure
without this Arc fan favorite stories
like the variety and arlang park would
be nearly as good as they end up
becoming we care about these arcs and
the moments that Spawn from them
partially because Oda is so considerate
and meticulous with how he constructs
and paces his stories leveraging the
time the early arcs offer him to make
something spectacular and even if we
stop looking at what orange Town offers
the later arcs it's still incredibly fun
bogey is hilarious and his fight with
Luffy is surprisingly memorable
furthermore it's the arc that made me
cry for the very first time that little
dog trying to protect his treasure to
this day drifts into my memories with
all of that said for me orange town is
again an easy a-tier entry on this list
next up syrup Village Arc this Arc is
very solid introducing us to the
character of usop and offering us up a
nice chance to see a more Sinister
villain along with a team a moment at
the end it's very good but it's not my
favorite part of the East blue material
and that's honestly because I personally
didn't find it as easy an arc to cover
compared to the rest of the arcs in this
Saga while it does act as usaf's
introduction as well as establishing all
of his idiosyncrasies and moral code it
does so through an arc that drags on a
tad too long unlike Zorro and Nami who
have their origin largely drip fed over
the next few arcs and sagas usop gets
explored a lot more in this making it
feel much more like a conventional or
should I say cliche Arc and it's not
really helped by Captain Kuro I like his
reveal I like the surprise he's involved
in but he's not nearly as fun to watch
when compared to Buggy and this Arc is
much longer than that with all that said
while more conventional than other parts
of the Saga in execution it succeeds in
pretty much everything he sets out to
achieve looking back I like this Arc
fine it's by no means something that
should be skipped either I think I'll
slot this one in tier B yeah that sounds
about right
[Music]
well it's time for some grub now as we
try to rank the Marathi a Arc this boat
looks like a fish and let me tell you
something fishy is certainly afoot
specifically sanji's feet because he
does the kicking stuff okay yeah
whatever hilarious jokes aside when I
started reading one piece I was told to
read up to the variety for the first
video and I'm really happy that I did
out of the arcs covered in the first
review video I made Link in the corner
it's easily the best and I'm not just
saying that for the memes in addition to
this Arc establishing Sanji perfectly
and delivering the best final battle the
series had seen so far this Arc also
builds the world of one piece in ways
more significant than anything that came
before it establishing a trend in
delivering story beats that not only
keep us at the edge of our seats with
nami peasing under the end dragging us
into Ireland Park but also gives us our
first taste of just how massive and
imposing The Wider world of One Piece
truly is with mihawk's introduction
re-contextualizing the initial chapters
of the one piece's story itself and
setting expectations that this story
absolutely knocks out of the park in
breathtaking fashion later on down the
line packaged all within a simple story
that absolutely doesn't outstay its
welcome it also has one of the most
badass lines that to this day I still
think about
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie I really want to give
this an s-tier ranking I love it so much
most probably won't rate it so highly
but this is the arc that hooked me to
one piece I love this Arc but do I like
it more than what comes next no no I
don't because what's next is arlong Park
this is where I introduce you all to the
hidden tier on this list because Arline
Park is God's tier if broughtier was the
arc that hooked me then arlang Park was
the arc that convinced me that this
little heisis Adventure was something
genuinely special there are a few
moments from my time reading manga where
our story has delivered so perfectly in
a way I as a reader never saw coming
what had been a kid-friendly story with
Luffy and his Pal's journey across the
East blue suddenly and without warning
becomes a much more mature story of
trust betrayal and the single best
friendship moment I'd ever seen
committed to the pages of any manga up
until that point the entire Narrative of
the Ark had been built around that one
moment and you definitely know the one
and it's delivery of that narrative beat
squeezed every last tier from my face in
ways that to this day I still feel a
little bit comfortable talking about it
benefits from all the build up over the
last few arcs and on top of that bonds
us to these characters in ways that both
make sense in the moment and surprise me
completely with how Oda approached it
our Long Park is god tier end of story
enough said moving on to low Town log
town is a weird one it's a brilliant Arc
that without us knowing sets up so much
for later on in the story highlighting
oda's writing chops and I think that out
of every Arc in the East blue material
it was the one that made the least
emotional or intellectual impact on me
personally in hindsight it's amazing
offering up questions the answers of
which we won't know for a damn long time
all wrapped in a short tail that is
filled with more symbolism than actual
story and that's not necessarily a bad
thing but you see that's the thing in
the moment it's somewhat exciting but
it's fleeting and with the grand line
immediately after this I was eager to
press onward past it which was probably
exactly what Oda wanted me to do Lord
knows what happened later in the story
surprised me following this so I'm sort
of up to two minds about this on one
hand I could view it through the lens of
me reading it for the very first time I
liked the story this had which presented
some conflict and was ultimately a stop
off before something bigger or on the
other hand I could rate it based on what
it achieved in the story in hindsight
one's a b tier and the other is a for me
oh okay I think I'm gonna have to go a
it's very good a tier for loc town and
now we press onward to the Grand line
[Music]
God this is gonna be a long video the
reverse Mountain Arc much the same way
the East blue Saga was structured the
alabaster Saga is composed of
effectively four stepping stone arcs
each more story driven than the last
before climaxing in the finale of The
Saga in spectacular fashion however I'd
argue that while this has a stronger
finish than the East blue Saga does in
some respects it starts out in a
comparatively less enjoyable fashion in
my opinion notice also how I said less
enjoyable not bad it's still super
enjoyable with reverse Mountain pulling
off a satisfactory introduction to the
Grand line complete with appropriate
levels of mystery suspense and action
there is something of a story contained
in this act however but feels much more
like a First Act compared to other
opening arcs in this series it's filled
with secrets and hints towards the
future and the moon story is always a
sweet and tragic one however I need to
make a decision and while there's plenty
in this that I like I think I'd
personally give it a b
whiskey Peak Arc I'd argue this one is
worse again not bad please don't kill me
I have a family I just like it less than
the others put your pitchforks down of
all the arcs that make up the alabaster
Saga this one I found to be the weakest
when I was reading it in 2020. with
Luffy taking the word of a random
stranger over his ally Zorro effectively
choosing to try and kill him based
entirely on a single stranger's
statement against Zorro's character was
in my opinion a rare example of odor
writing Luffy out of character and the
worst part is that this very Choice Is
Fundamental to the continuation of this
Arc and therefore the greater story
outside of this the story itself is fine
in the characters on display are cool
getting the chance to learn about and
spend more time with Vivi but I think
out of all the arcs so far for me this
has to be the weakest it does have this
incredibly intimidating scene with Nico
Robin that to this day is still stuck in
my head but I don't think that's enough
to save this Arc from becoming the
lowest ranked thus far C tier thankfully
however the back end of this Saga is
much stronger than its opening foreign
thank you so much to athletic greens for
sponsoring today's video they were kind
enough to send across their wonderful
comprehensive all-in-one greens powder
called ag1 by athletic greens I've
already run a marathon this year and I
have one more to come so joining up with
athletic greens made perfect sense and
I'm glad to be able to work with them
once again their ag1 powder has made
keeping up with nutrition really easy
there's no need to manage all these
different Health tablets when this stuff
has and bear with me here there's a lot
75 vitamins minerals Whole Foods Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens all
within one single easy to make daily
serving you just mix one scoop with
water and your favorite smoothie or
juice shake it up and you're good to go
it's got a fairly earthy taste with a
sweet Edge the intensity of which is
really easy to control based on how much
liquid you add and what type which is
being great for someone like me who is
usually horrified by green looking stuff
it really is a simple all-in-one option
and has helped me feel a great Boost
energy throughout the day especially off
the back of workout sessions where quick
recovery is a blessing if this sounds
healing then you'll be happy to hear
athletic greens have been kind enough to
offer you guys a whole year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase so if that
sounds good be sure to click the link in
the description now again there's a
year's supply of vitamin D3 K2 and 5
travel packs for free with your first
purchase ag1 provides your body with
everything it needs for Optimal
Performance every single day this is a
game changer for supporting your immune
system and I can't recommend it enough
it is really great now
[Music]
little garden little garden is a delight
and really captured my imagination in a
big way one piece on its face is already
a story that feels like it was
tailor-made for me what with every
island effectively acting as a new
mystery for me to uncover the secrets
within and let me tell you with little
garden Auto leverages that two wonderful
effect the jungle environments are
brilliant the story of the two giants
fighting was both humorous if not
somewhat sad and the fight with Mr three
and his wax wax fruit abilities created
some of the most memorable moments out
of any fight for me to this day zoro's
striking that cool guy pose in case he
can't get out gets me good and Sanji
side quest answering the phone to folks
way higher up on the totem pole is the
cherry on top every choice feels true to
the characters and overall it's just a
really fun Arc to revisit it's an easy a
tier entry for me
drum Island
earlier in the video I mentioned that I
had largely not viewed the anime safe
for perhaps one or two moments where I
needed to take a look either because the
animation was so good or because my
perspective seemed to be so disconnected
from The Wider public this was the
latter drum island is wonderful touching
and moreover offers a wonderful
introduction to the character of Chopper
that to this day captures the hearts of
millions but strangely it didn't have
that effect on me as stories go this is
brilliant with a Salient and touching
message in keeping with the ethics and
morals of the series in general the
polar environment offers a nice contrast
to the tropical island hopping and again
offers plenty of moments for me to latch
onto as a viewer to many this is easily
an S tier story and maybe even god tier
but honestly for me it's an a at best
where others would choke up upon hearing
Dr hiterduk's dying words reach Chopper
it was for me that very character that I
had a near impossible task of learning
to love while I can't see and appreciate
that he has some endearing qualities in
the manga he's depicted as much more
nefarious and dare I say selfish forcing
himself into the homes of innocent
people terrifying them and ultimately
either doing them more harm than help at
best and I understand that the message
is you need to love what you do and then
pursue it earnestly and that he really
wanted to help these people but if what
you're doing is having the exact
opposite effect on these people and
traumatizes these little children
then maybe stop doing what you're doing
huh hidden Oak's situation is presented
as this oppressive misunderstanding and
there is truth in that but hiriduk
honestly came across as utterly insane
to me in the manga whereas in the anime
he's much more likable by comparison I
admire his passion and the closing words
of his speech are perfect for a
character like Chopper who thankfully
isn't a terrible doctor like this guy
was despite this however the story has
some breathtaking moments like Luffy
protecting hiriduk's flag from what was
unfortunately the most annoying and
uninteresting villain I had seen so far
in the series but the more I think about
it the more I want to put this in the
beat here it's got some really high
Highs but the lows for me are rather
pronounced too I think I'll be
charitable and put this in the a tier
foreign
piece
comfortably sits atop the god tier much
the same way arlong Park offered a ton
of catharsis and payoff to everything
that was set up in East blue Alabaster
so too benefits from this same narrative
Advantage delivering payoff after payoff
emotional gut punch after emotional gut
punch not the least of which to this day
remains as iconic a manga panel as any
other in history but even outside of
that the scale of this Arc feels immense
and like a really natural progression
with villains desert the crew and indeed
Luffy himself he loses badly in this Arc
but manages to come back from adversity
showing his Innovative mind commitment
to his team and the real grit and
tenacity that a leader like him needs
the small story of the old man in the
desert with Luffy really speaks to who
he is as a character furthermore this
also gives everyone in the cast plenty
to do given that Luffy is effectively
sidelined for a decent chunk of the
runtime The Arc is action-packed
touching and filled to the brim with
tremendous World building also Mr two
eat I say more Alabaster is an easy god
tier entry it's stupidly great even to
this day the giant Arc these next two
arcs I got the sense while I was reading
and reviewing them weren't exactly
favorites amongst the one piece
Community however Jaya and skypier felt
like they were made for me however I
will say that Jaya feels less like an
arc and more like a short setup or First
Act there's not much of a story although
it is utterly gorgeous in how the island
is depicted in the manga with the story
of knowing the liar acting as the
framework and lens through which we
understand the story moving ahead into
the comparatively much longer and
detailed skypier Arc as introductions go
this has a lot of mystery and suspense
with plenty of World building and
character much of which I still think
about to this day I really enjoyed it
while I was reading it too I think I'll
give this one
[Music]
this was such a cool idea for a story
for Moda taking clear inspiration from
stories and historical events that have
interested me throughout my life whether
you think of it as some Fantastical or
fairy tale-like approach with this
mystery land in the clouds or whether
you think of it as a rip roaring
adventure of Discovery like the Voyages
into America all those centuries ago
this Arc also delivers in Spades with
one of the most memorable and humorous
villains in the series Eminem I've heard
a lot of people complain about how this
Arc is slow however when it came to my
experience with the manga while it was
longer than the other arcs that came
before it by no means felt belabored or
slow maybe the anime has a lot of filler
in this section I don't know the
revelations and closure we get from this
Arc through either the map being
completed the mystery being uncovered or
even Robin's little side quest further
hinting to an underlying story that only
the eagle-eyed and attentive will fully
appreciate the only question is whether
I should put it in s tier or god tier
ironically containing the Rap God
himself I think I'd still prefer to keep
God tears somewhat exclusive fit only
for the best of the best I love Skype
yes so let's say it rests comfortably at
the top of s tier right now
long ring long land Arc this one
surprised me not by how good or bad it
was but by how many people online either
thought it was a filler Arc or
absolutely hated it and again that
wasn't my experience long ring long land
is a fun and cute Arc with a challenge
and some fun moments for
characterization mostly silly but there
are some serious moments towards the end
too there's not really much to be angry
about or much to even comment on I have
no idea why people give King wapple a
pass for how annoying and terrible of a
character he is but give foxy all of his
criticism long ring long land is a
perfectly fine B tier Arc totally
inoffensive
come on
[Music]
Water Seven Ark all right people get
angry at me over this routinely but
again I'll say it for now I'm a much
bigger fan of story than action and
despite any zlabby being everyone's
favorite part of these two arcs water 7
was and remains to be this day the one I
found to be the most enjoyable first of
all the World building in this part of
the story is next level and honestly the
strongest in the series up until now the
way the city itself is conceived of and
plays into the narrative in fundamental
ways through the C train was genius and
on top of that weaved into the fabric of
the very Arc itself are a Litany of
colorful and Sinister characters veiled
behind the mystery that steals away
Robin from her allies thus setting up
the battles of any zlabi perfectly and
despite my saying that water 7 was more
story focused than action-focused it
plays host my favorite fight in the
series Luffy versus USA less a battle of
Brawn and strategy and more so one of
emotions and morals this fight pushes
both of these fan favorite characters to
their emotional and physical breaking
points respectively and
it's incredible the dialogue surrounding
that aspect of the story might also be
the strongest and most natural of its
kind in the series too there are other
points in the story that hooked me
greatly but this is up there as a
contender for my top three easily
furthermore words cannot describe just
how much I adored this overarching story
concerning the going Mary's ultimate end
it's so well conceived of and thought
through this Arc just about has
everything I could ask for in a story it
has just the right amount of mystery and
character in pretty much every way I can
think of we get to meet Frankie for the
first time and that ending with Sanji
being the one waiting at the C train for
Robin was the perfect hook to drag me
into the fabled Annie's Lobby section s
tier doesn't do this one Justice for me
this is easily god tier I loved quarter
seven
Annie's Lobby Arc
it's okay
oh this Arc is so damn good too though
talk about an arc Head To Toe with
suspense and drama if water 7 was the
act one and two of the story that anys
Lobby is the climaxing finale naturally
due to it dealing primarily with a
considerable amount of payoff there
isn't a lot of wiggle room here for
newly introduced Concepts or story beats
however that also helps this Arc remain
focused and I would argue that's the
strength it possesses with the primary
goal being that of rescuing Rob and
everything else the Gang has been
dealing with suddenly becomes secondary
leading to this tremendous section on
the C train as well as their eventual
infiltration into enes Lobby against one
of the scummiest characters in the
entire series cp9 gets some great shine
in this also with all of them becoming
these strange devil fruit users the
giraffe one is my favorite however the
Highlight for me has to be Luchi versus
Luffy and of course Robin's Declaration
of what she truly wants in life to live
it's an exciting turbulent and
satisfying ending to an incredible
section of this manga with the going
Mary receiving her swan song amidst her
final rest Rescue of the crew that she
granted safe passage across the grand
line while I can say I enjoyed it more
than water 7 it still is a comfortable s
tier candidate
post any Lobby Arc the post and his
Lobby material is extremely difficult to
rank on this list in any sort of
meaningful capacity even if you account
for my own subjectivity in my opinion
there's too much that happens in this
section for it to be considered
uneventful and far too little Story
meets the beginning and ending in this
section to be considered substantive I
think the best way to look at this Arc
is as an epilogue wherein we get the
conclusion to usop's conflict with the
crew in Luffy that might be also my
favorite part and a strong focus on new
material like Luffy's family situation
with dragon and his grandpa GARP there's
also this crazy encounter between Ace
and Blackbeard to round out the drama of
the occasion also it's certainly a
memorable section and one that offers a
character appropriate conclusion to some
of the lingering storylines concerning
the crew their ship and of course as I
mentioned usopp's relationship with them
all the while expanding the scope of the
series by offering answers and adding
new questions to the back of her
Collective minds I think all in all
somewhere around a tier is okay for this
one
Thriller bark I don't love Thriller park
and if you've seen my review you'll know
why although I think it has some of the
coolest ideas for an environment in the
series what was it effectively being a
Giant floating Ghost Ship the size of an
island there are also some great comedic
exchanges in this with a large part of
the humor only being possible in this
very area with that said I wasn't
massively entertained by the villain of
this Arc at all and I found that in
Parts particularly towards the end the
pacing suffered quite a lot in the
action sequences with that said I will
say that it does have its stronger
moments too the nothing happened moment
with Zorro is again one of those moments
from the series that enjoys a
well-deserved iconic status but with
that said overall Thriller Park just
didn't Thrill Me many might disagree
with this but I'd give it a c personally
[Music]
and so Begins the greatest stretch of
one piece in my opinion
kicking things off in superb fashion
through shibaudi archipelago what a way
to kick off this story I mean come on as
mentioned prior I try to keep it in
perspective what the goal of each of
these respective arcs is when I make my
final subjective ranking at the end and
while I was reading this I was relaxed
intrigued and attentive until boom
suddenly everything goes to hell and my
brain starts scrambling trying to make
sense of what just took place they all
lost they all died what what now the
mystery the despair the chaos this Arc
leaves us with is nothing short of
remarkable creating for this upcoming
story perhaps the best set up the
franchises ever managed easy S2
Amazon Lily Arc Amazon Lily managed to
achieve something I had specifically
been waiting for this series to focus on
since I started reading while there were
moments here and there that highlighted
the strengths and utility of the crew
for sure the very purpose of this Arc is
to point out and draw attention to how
limited and in need of his team Luffy
truly is right off the back of
everything that happened in water 7 in
his lobby with the likes of Luchi Luffy
someone that had clearly been singled
out as the leader we're reminded in this
Arc is still just one of many just one
part of what makes his crew so effective
Together made evident by his sheer
inability to look after himself and find
his way around the jungle of Amazon Lily
furthermore the battle with the snake
ladies was brilliant and highlighted the
intangible faction that makes Luffy the
person worthy of leading the straw hat
pirates in the first place it's all so
brilliantly handled focusing our
attention specifically on what Luffy
lost and now he has to go and save his
brother from being executed uh okay I
think if this and this about the
archipelago abide into one Arc together
I would consider them God tier but alas
they are separate and so s tier shall be
the verdict for both s tier for Amazon
Lily loved this Arc
[Music]
impel down Arc this is a crazy
suspenseful Arc has the funniest set of
panels in the one piece story I believe
and above all else bills the mystery and
suspense around the world even more all
within the confines of the deep and dark
impel down prison system no more are the
open and Lush jungles of Amazon Lily
coding our Pages we are instead trapped
within a dark and gritty place now
within which Luffy uncovers the hidden
tortures cultures and circumstances of
the prisoners that lurk in the depths of
this prison it's such a fascinating
choice for an arc and one that
demonstrates Luffy's strengths as a main
character yet again proving his real
power is his ability to get people to
cooperate with him to believe in him
this is another easy s tier entry for me
Marine
[Music]
fighting
for me the best part of one piece is its
World building the frenetic and chaotic
energy that helps to populate the world
with life culture civilians Pirates
politics and Navy personnel this sense
of generational power and reputation
that exists in one piece even outside of
the mystery surrounding Goldie Roger is
enough to enthrall me in this epic
conclusion to this trend setting Arc
that raises the bar that one piece had
itself previously said I think the
helpful thing about concluding my
decision or placement pertaining to this
Arc itself is that I don't really need
to justify it this Arc is so spectacular
in grinding scope and yet manages to
deliver a very focused in human story
surrounding Luffy and his brother as
well as the passing of the Taurus to the
Next Generation and surprisingly I
managed to read this moment completely
unspoiled as Oda intended and boy did I
feel that page turn there's no question
that Marine Ford is god tier you know it
I know it it's not the most
controversial take in this video let me
tell you foreign
[Music]
if you thought the post and these Lobby
stuff was great this takes everything
that epilogue offered up multiplies its
Effectiveness by 10 and creates a
cliffhanger so brutal I needed to start
reading what followed right away despite
it being the time that I was supposed to
take a break for a number of weeks
getting to see some backstory for Luffy
was both tragic and engaging and
watching on as he struggles to find the
will to go on following the harrowing
events of marineford are difficult to
sit and read through even knowing where
their story continues on to there's not
really much else I can say about this
Arc that you all don't already know and
that I haven't already gushed about in
another video Simply put this is a god
tier entry God tears kind of getting
crowded might have to invent a new tier
soon
next up return to shaboudi all right
guys we're finally on the home stretch
only uh eight more to go God one piece
is so damn long the return is about he
hinges largely on the reintroduction of
the straw head Pirates after their two
year long training stint I think if I
condensed all of my feelings about this
Arc into a single word that word would
be surprising and not for the reasons
you might be suspecting if reviewing
this taught me anything about the review
process or how I should or should not
approach a critique is that I need to
account for the context within which my
viewers or fans of the material might
have experienced that material compared
to me I stressed this a number of times
in my review series but I'll never be
able to grow up with one piece the same
way that you all did watching it today
I'll never be able to share that
experience and have that same nostalgic
flavor to the series that I'm sure a
number of you routinely enjoy how we
digest media when we digest media the
mood with which we digest media in and
the context within which we read or
watch it helps to create a specific
experience for us as fans of the story
this is why I say that my experience
with one piece is more than likely
totally different to 99 of the people
out there watching as I experienced it
in the context of sharing it with an
online audience it completely changes
things however when a story can bridge
that divide if just for a moment I think
it's worth pointing out and despite my
only taking a week off from this series
while I was reviewing it the strange
feeling of nostalgia I felt while
reuniting with the straw hats was
something I never expected and won't
soon forget either I had only known them
for a few months at that point and for
whatever reason in this moment it felt
like I had known them my entire life the
ark is largely reintroductioned and set
up but I really enjoyed it nevertheless
I'll give this one
was man island arc Fishman island is one
of those arcsa Series has that a large
portion of its fan base doesn't seem to
resonate with or enjoy that much
personally I found it to be way better
than Thriller Park and quite
entertaining from start to finish give
or take a few instances where I felt
like it might have dragged to here and
there in terms of World building and
placement in the universe of One Piece
Fishman island is up there with some of
my favorite locations in the series it's
such a wonderfully creative idea for a
civilization ripe with Secrets new
challenges unique to Dela fruit users
coupled with a fight that has a lot of
social commentary within the world of
one piece that becomes relevant in later
arcs like the reverie it's got tons of
exciting fights insightful flashbacks
and so so much more I think I'd like
this one a lot more than most that's why
I'm giving it an a tier ranking on this
list
[Music]
Punk Hazard Arc this is where I think
I'm gonna make some enemies I said it in
the video review for Punk Hazard a while
back and I'll say it again this Arc just
did not click with me when I read it and
I swear I don't have anything against
Snow Islands I just happened not to
resonate that much with the two snow
islands that there were in this series
there are of course aspects to the story
that I enjoyed much is the case with
every story arc in one piece the
Mysteries associated with the narrative
are some of my favorite Bits And if the
World building of that story could help
to facilitate that mystery and Intrigue
then all the better the First Act of
this Arc I personally found to be the
most interesting and enjoyable learning
of the history of punk Hazard as well as
the Battle of snow and fire that took
place there was awesome and some of the
sequences inside the lab facility were
cool too Momo to name but a few it's an
arc that has a lot of components of what
make a great one piece Arc work but
whether it was my disinterest in the
goal of the story or if it was perhaps
bogged down in setups for later arcs
down the line what with dressrosa being
directly connected to it and right
around the corner as well as the early
setup for the big reveal Trader eduano
with this being of course the
introduction of the Samurai also I just
felt like I was waiting more than
anything for Punk Hazard To End while I
was reading it and that's a shame it
does a great job of establishing stuff
for later but the things that are local
to this Arc by itself that I liked
became fewer and farther between as the
arc went down I think this one is a seat
here for me
dressrosa Arc dressrosa is oddly enough
another one of those arcs I hear people
complain about online but I really had a
lot of fun with this one from the side
quests with the dwarves to the
tournament Luffy takes part in towards
the beginning to the core story of this
land featuring doflamingo's Corruption
of this land's royalty and that's not
even to make mention of the surprise
return of Sabo nabbing for himself the
objectively coolest devil fruit in the
one piece Universe the flame flame fruit
foreign
they made me not hate Fantastic Four in
2005. dressrosa does have its downsides
however the sheer number of times Daffy
is thought to have been bested only for
him to come back again and again and
again became very annoying very fast
however between the flame flame fruit
Sabo the new scary Navy guy and the
giant bird cage set piece in the finale
also God usop did I say more I think
dressrosa for me is an Easy A
[Music]
so Arc Zoe is a really really
interesting and cool idea and I'll tell
you from the outset that is on the
border between god tier and S tier for
me this is a brilliant Arc that achieves
so much in such a short span of time and
talk about an interesting Island idea I
thought Thriller back was creative this
is next level in every sense of the word
big elephant has big animals on body
that do big fight under big moon again
this is Oda just flexing his creative
muscles to the absolute Max in ways that
expand the world's scope considerably
and those are always the elements from
an arc I love the most whether it be
skypius Sky civilization water 7's water
Metropolis or indeed the dense jungles
of those Hidden Treasures the child in
me that awakens always has fun in these
scenarios and that's also ignoring that
there's a really sweet story told in
this one too I think because I'm unsure
which tier this should go in I'll put it
in Esther to be safe God to your picks
need to be solid picks from the start
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whole cake island arc whole cake island
is a whole lot of story a whole lot of
fighting a whole lot of plotting and a
whole lot of characters and jokes aside
has the best Sanji focused story since
the baratier which at this point in the
video feels like literally years since
I've last spoken about it here's a fun
fact halfway through this video I
discovered I had coveted so if my voice
has sounded hoarse at any point in this
video and suddenly sounded better that's
why but I digress regarding whole cake I
think my favorite aspect of it is the
VIN smoke family and sanji's
relationship with them through this we
learned the source of all of his
insecurities and walls that he puts up
to others we get pretty much the exact
opposite interaction Luffy had with usop
in water 7 but in all the best ways and
Luffy slaps the heck out of him at the
end the entire section with sanji's
heartbreak and then making a Resurgence
is in and of itself 10 out of 10
material then we have of action and
Luffy's fight with katakuri is on
another level the likes of which has
more depth than most single mangas have
in their entire run so it's an easy god
tier entry right well it would be if not
for the fact that I just found the
paneling in this section to be extremely
difficult to get through at times to say
the least unlike series like Dragon Ball
or chainsaw man one piece Cannon often
does find itself quite wordy and busy on
each individual page and that can be
fine for some people it's just not my
preference I'd prefer to read a book
than have to try and figure out a
complicated series of small panels any
day and for that reason alone I'm giving
this Arc an S tier
the Reverend and so now we have made it
to the reverie and the big
just got to say that again this much
like all the other Segway arcs in the
series left me with so many questions
the likes of which I couldn't even begin
to make sense of naturally I have
questions concerning the big chair but
there's also this weird pointy guy with
a weird eye and this this giant Frosty
straw hat like what
what a significance of that I ask you
does anyone have any idea because I
don't I'm gonna give this one an S tier
for how much it screw with my mind and
how cool it was getting to see everyone
from Vivi all the way to the mermaid
princess and finally juano country Arc
finally we are back at wano and those of
you that paid attention to my reviews in
2020 will remember that I said that
wanna was my favorite Arc so far but has
my statement changed since then when
will I finish my review series on this
Arc will it be soon wouldn't you like to
know well wano is clearly an arc that
Oda cares deeply about it has a rich
sense of identity tons happens in the
story and the battles twists turns and
developments that occur within this
Breezy 144 chapter short Arc are
eye-catching to say the least fun fact
the Raider nonagushima which I didn't
cover in my review series because I
thought it was going to be over soon has
on its own 77 chapters that's longer
than most manga ever get the chance to
be not even arcs it's longer than most
manga that are ever made get to be and
because I haven't given my opinion on
what turned out to be essentially the
second half of one or proper my ranking
in this video will be based on my
impression of The Arc in 2020 so as not
to spoil the review when I do make it
shortly so as of right now wano is God
too and that does it for this video we
will be taking a short break from
uploading next week and following that
will be a once off special review of
death note I love that series and I
can't wait to share that video with you
all a ton of work went into it and after
that who knows perhaps the one review is
coming sooner than you think until then
I've been totally not Mark and thank you
all so much for watching
foreign
[Music]